I'm getting really good at that
hey hey hey
hey guys I'm Abbi chart welcome to
Abby's kitchen we're rounding the bend
on those final long weekends of summer
and that calls for something sweet
creamy and cool
I am admittedly an ice-cream fiend I
will eat that stuff in the middle of a
Canadian blizzard at minus 30 it's a lot
better with that insulated gloves it's
still pretty good it's also a lot better
when you can eat a whole pint of the
stuff and still feel great afterwards so
that's where I was inspired to make this
via the Nana Nutella ice cream honestly
bananas are my favorite fruit ice cream
is my favorite dessert and Nutella is
pretty much my favorite food group so
you know this is gonna be awesome
alright so we've got these gorgeous ripe
bananas we're just gonna pop them into a
freezer bag and get them frozen until
solid all right
so into our food processor I'm gonna put
all those frozen bananas the riper they
are the better because they actually are
so super sweet on their own you don't
have to add any extra sugar that looks
creamy and smooth alright so now we're
going to layer in some crunchy treats
because I like a little crunch factor
with my smooth banana ice cream so a
little layer of the banana ice cream
into a freezer safe container I just use
like a little loaf pan or a baking dish
and lots of crunchy bits of hazelnuts so
good
and those cacao nibs too
so we're just gonna scoop our banana ice
cream oh yeah look at that and now we're
gonna drizzle it with this homemade
vegan Nutella you can check out the
recipe right here for you
little more crushed hazelnuts and some
pound news for crunch
sweet punchy smooth two very
enthusiastic thumbs thank you guys so
much for watching I would love to hear
what your favorite ice cream flavors are
so leave me a comment below give me a
thumbs up if you like this video
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen
subscribe
you